not only did he reinstate a third degree
murder charge not only did he refuse the
the defense's request to transfer the
trial out of minneapolis but now
he's basically barring the defense from
being able to admit testimony from the
drug dealer who was in the car with
george floyd
you know all that seems frankly
extraordinarily pro-prosecution
this brings us to the latest in the
derek chauvin trial so the derek chaven
trial continues to pace the defense
began laying out
its case yesterday and it was
basically two pieces of of
testimonial evidence that really
mattered in the defense case with regard
to derek shoving yesterday now listen if
i have to ballpark where i think this is
going
i don't think there's a chance in the
world that chovin actually gets
acquitted i i think that given the
nature of the jury the fact this is
taking place in minneapolis i think it's
very doubtful you
you need a unanimous jury to either
convict or to acquit so i think the most
likely outcome here is a hung jury i
think you'll get a couple of jurors who
say we're not going to convict on the
basis of this evidence
you might get a conviction on the basis
of the manslaughter i think the murder
charges are way too far i think they
were always way too far i think
manslaughter
is at the very least somewhat
understandable coming from the jury
maybe if you view the evidence through
through a very skeptical prism toward
the defense
okay but i think the most likely outcome
here is a hung jury
so there are two pieces of evidence that
were trotted out yesterday with regard
to the chauvin trial
piece of evidence number one was this
old arrest in 2019
because it looks a lot like the arrest
that happened
in 2020 with regard to george floyd and
arrester in which he died his behavior
during one is sort of indicative of his
behavior
during the other the other piece of
evidence was a bunch of testimony from a
police use of force expert named barry
broad
who basically testified that chauvin's
use of force here was reasonable
okay well that is what the defense needs
to show broad's testimony i will say was
was not
stellar the the body cam footage from
the 2019 arrest is more probative
okay so we're gonna go through all of
that because remember what the defense
has to show here or what the prosecution
has to prove and the fantastic debunk
is one that that floyd died of
not a drug overdose or any underlying
condition but died because of what
chovin did
and two the defense the prosecution has
to show
that chauvin's use of force was
objectively unreasonable
that it was unlawful okay so the defense
has to show contrarily
that no it's not beyond a reasonable
doubt that it could have been reasonable
use of force and two
floyd could have died from these other
causes okay that's what a lot of the
test
testimony was about yesterday okay so we
begin with
with the 2019 arrest
there there were a couple of pieces of
testimony here that actually mattered
one was the actual body cam footage from
the 2019 arrest
in which it was shown in court that
floyd had swallowed evidence when he was
arrested presumably drugs that's what
you swallow so it wasn't like a bag of
cash
he swallowed some of the evidence and
the idea here
presumably is that floyd could have done
the same thing here
that as the cops were approaching he put
a bunch of pills in his mouth those
pills drove up
his heart rate and then drove his heart
right down and then he died right that
would be the case that the defense is
making here they're saying he did the
same things in 2019
it just went a lot more wrong in this
particular case and there's some
ancillary evidence to that effect namely
that there were spit-out pills in the
back of the cop car
that were laced apparently with meth and
fentanyl here is the
the flashback 2019 tape from george
floyd's arrest
back then all right come on
okay put them on your head
open your mouth spit out what you got
spit out what you got i'm gonna tease
you
spit it out come
okay so he obviously was not complying
with officer orders there he tried to
swallow the evidence and so what the
defense was claiming is he did the same
thing here
michelle mohsing was a paramedic in that
particular case
and she said that i talked to floyd and
floyd said at the time that he was
addicted to pain pills and he took seven
to nine percocet that is a lot of
percocet gang
right percocet is basically just
oxycontin here's the here's the
paramedic in this particular case
he told you that he swallowed some pills
right yes
uh approximately seven percocet correct
[Applause]
i documented yeah seven to nine
every 20 minutes or so for a while so he
told you that he
had been taking those pills throughout
the day right
yes and he i asked him why he said he's
because he was addicted
okay so the the drug addiction case is
going to be a case that is pushed pretty
heavily by the defense in terms of the
causation
again there's an intervening cause
they're going to say the intervening
cause was floyd's
dramatic drug use the intervening cause
was floyd's heart condition now one of
the things that's happening here also is
the prosecution is forcibly attempting
to suppress witness testimony
so the defense argued in front of the
jury
guys his drug dealer was in the car with
him the prosecution could offer that guy
immunity in return for his testimony
they won't do it
why do you think they won't do it could
it be because he's about to testify
that he is complicit in the death of
george floyd
by giving him a bunch of drugs in the
car because why else would you have your
drug dealer in the car with you
right so that's something the defense is
arguing they're also pointing out that
there's other testimony
that this guy had for example an fbi
interview for like an hour and a half
and none of that testimony is being
admitted in court
there are going to be some cases on
appeal here the judge's behavior in this
particular case i have to say
is extraordinarily pro-prosecution not
only did he allow a week of testimony
of a very little probative value
promotive means actually goes toward
proving the case he allowed a week of
testimony from bystanders talking about
how upset they were by floyd's death
which is not probative in any way it is
just prejudicial
not only did he do that not only did he
reinstate a third degree murder charge
that certainly does not fit the elements
here not only did he refuse the
the defense's request to transfer the
trial out of minneapolis
where it's very difficult to get a fair
trial but now he's basically barring the
defense
from asking questions about excited
delirium to prosecution witnesses he's
barring the defense
from from being able to admit testimony
from the drug dealer who was in the car
with george floyd
you know all that seems frankly
extraordinarily pro-prosecution okay so
the other piece of evidence that came
out in the chauvin trial yesterday
was uh the police use of force expert
his name is barry broad
i don't think he did a fantastic job
frankly he was trying
to argue that chauvin's use of force was
justified
and there's a good case to make that his
use of force was justified here was
very broad saying that chovin was
justified in his use of force using a
three-pronged analysis
so was the officer's use of force
proportionate to the level of resistance
demonstrated by the suspect
objectively reasonable correct yes
so in terms of your three-part analysis
did you apply
that analysis to this case i did
in your opinion was this a use of deadly
force it was not
and can you just briefly overview your
opinions
in this particular case i felt that
derek chauvin was
justified and was acting with objective
reasonableness following minneapolis
police department policy
and current standards of law enforcement
and his interactions with mr floyd
so the three-pronged analysis that he
used to determine this he said
if the officer had justification to
detain the suspect which she did how the
suspect responded to the officer and if
the officer's use of force was
proportionate to the level of resistance
demonstrated by the suspect it's that
last one
whether the officer's use of force was
proportionate to the level of resistance
demonstrated by the suspect
that's the one that's really at issue
because it's clear that floyd was
resisting arrest
it is clear that the officer had
justification to detain the suspect
because the suspect
was passing counterfeit bills and
resisting arrest
the real question is whether chauvin was
justified in keeping floyd face down
and then staying on him as he passed out
here's broad explaining why he thinks
they were justified in keeping floyd
face down in the first place
why would it be safer for the suspect to
keep him in that prone control
because if they were to get up and run
handcuffed trip and fall sustained
facial injuries
other injuries on the ground their
mobility is reduced
their ability to move is reduced and the
ability to hurt themselves is reduced
what if they became sick for example
front control
instead of having somebody lay on their
back where they could aspirate on vomit
prone control their face is down airway
is clear
if they vomit it's not going to go down
their trachea or down their throat
okay so that's actually a pretty good
piece of testimony in favor of the
defense that what chovin was doing here
is basic police protocol
where the where this witness you know
really screwed up
is he said that that was no use of force
that when you're suppressing floyd by
being on his back that is a no use of
force that of course is very silly it is
a it is a form of use of force
it is just a very low level use of force
is what he really should have said and
the prosecution of course jumped on this
with both feet
a compliant person would have both their
hands in the small their back and just
be resting
comfortably versus like he's still
moving around
did you say resting comfortably or
laying comfortably
resting comfortably on the pavement yes
at this point in time when he's
attempting to breathe
by shoving his shoulder into the
pavement i was describing what
the signs of a perfectly compliant
person would be
so attempting to breathe while
restrained is a
being slightly non-compliant no
no okay so so there the prosecution is
honing in on what they think is the the
defense
use of force experts overstatement of
the case what the defense use of force
expert was attempting to say presumably
is that if floyd had been compliant all
the way throughout he would not have
been kicking at the officers
he would have not been attempting to
push against the officers who had been
lying there and then they basically
would have just been
either sitting on top of them or not
sitting on top of them at all
okay here's the bottom line again the
defense does not have to prove
that chovin is innocent they just have
to prove beyond a reason not beyond a
reasonable doubt
the prosecution has to prove beyond a
reasonable doubt so we'll see what the
rest of the witness testimony tends to
show
again my guess is that chauvin ends up
convicted of manslaughter if he's
convicted of anything and a hung jury is
a not
implausible outcome in this particular
case if there's a hung jury there will
be rioting
extraordinary rioting if he's convicted
of manslaughter there may be rioting
because people will just say well he
should have been convicted of murder and
this is how the media has set up this
narrative
even though the evidence here is quite
shaded even though this is a much more
complex story than people were
originally led to believe
the media have set this thing up for
riots and riots you shall receive
because we now live in an america in
which
police killings that are unjustified are
statistically extremely rare they are
very very rare in the united states
given the number of interactions between
police and suspects but you know what is
not rare
whenever there is a controversial
situation caught on tape
or even not caught on tape between a
white police officer
and a black suspect you can be assured
that in at least 50 of cases i would
imagine
there is some form of rioting or looting
that breaks out into the public
if it's high profile enough that
whenever one of these things becomes
public
there is writing and looting and we we
should not live in a country where we
expect that sort of behavior because
american citizens have a right to expect
two things that don't conflict with each
other one that they are not going to be
unjustifiably
killed by the police or mistreated by
the police and two that their fellow
american citizens
should not be allowed to roam around
looting and rioting
and doing great violence and harm these
are not conflicting
ideas they're perfectly in consonance
with one another but the media have set
them up in complete
opposite to one another because the idea
is that if the cops do something wrong
then riots and looting if not justified
are at least understandable and that's
the way the media has been covering this
stuff throughout that is the soft
bigotry of low expectations
it would not be allowed under any other
rubric in american life but the media
have basically decided
as nicole hannah jones said 16 19 riots
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content